(groaning)
(soft dramatic music)
- Just when we thought
Spider-Man was going
to be the new face of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
for years to come a stand
off between Disney and Sony
could put a stop to it.
So what does this mean for the future
of the MCU and Spider-Man?
Let's discuss right now on The Ketchup.
I can't believe I'm saying this
but after failed negotiations
Marvel Studios President, Kevin
Feige, will not be involved
in the next two planned Spider-Man movies.
And the character,
whose film rights are
held by Sony Pictures,
will no longer be available
to Marvel Studios.
This isn't the Daily Bugle guys!
This is happening and it's wild.
- [Peter] I don't understand.
- As far as what this means for the MCU,
well all that talk about Spider-Man
being the next Iron
Man in "Far From Home,"
plus Nick Fury wanting him
to help out up in space
means he was going to be a major player
in phase five or six.
So this is gonna be a tough
web for them to untangle.
And this whole time I thought
Spider-Man ghosting Nick Fury was a joke!
- You do not ghost Nick Fury!
- Let's talk about the
future of Spider-Man.
Since having your own cinematic universe
is totally a thing now
Sony's planning to expand
upon the Spider-Verse,
which has about 900
characters to choose from.
That's a lot of characters!
And coming off of the heels
of 2018's certified fresh,
Oscar winning animated movie
"Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse,"
Sony also has a sequel to "Venom,"
starring Tom Hardy, coming next year.
And projects for characters
like Kraven the Hunter,
Silver Sable and Black Cat
are also in development.
Plus a movie with Morbius
the Living Vampire
played by Jared Leto
is also coming in 2021.
- Blah, blah, blah.
- As for the upcoming Spider-Man movies
even with Tom Holland and
director Jon Watts returning
it might get kinda weird
not being able to reference things
like Peter's journey with the MCU,
his connections to Stark Industries,
not to mention the motivation
behind Jake Gyllenhaal's Mysterio,
and on top of all of that,
there's poor Tom Holland
stuck in the middle of all of this.
And I think we all know how he feels
about playing Spider-Man
because, well, he told me.
- I honestly would play Spider-Man
until like I can't walk anymore.
- Basically this all comes down to money!
Disney, who owns Marvel,
wants to do an even split
of all future Spider-Man films.
But Sony said no and wants to keep
the current deal where it stands
which means Marvel gets a
small percentage of the gross.
In other words, they just don't want
to share their biggest franchise.
And this is despite the fact
that the Fiege produced
"Spider-Man Far From Home" film
recently became Sony's
highest grossing movie ever!
And maybe that's just it.
Looking to the near future,
Marvel's phase four films
slated for the next couple years
actually don't have
much to do with Spidey.
The upcoming sequel,
"Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness,"
will most likely take
place far from Manhattan
where Peter was just revealed
and blamed for everything.
So, I guess he'll just be in hiding
till he can clear his name?
I mean, literally!
And that could mean Shang-Chi,
with the movie coming in 2021,
will take a more central role in the MCU.
And Sony is definitely feeling the heat
and shouldering most of
the blame on social media.
So they put out a series
of tweets saying, quote,
"Much of today's news about Spider-Man
"has mischaracterized recent discussions
"about Kevin Feige's
involvement in the franchise.
"We are disappointed but
respect Disney's decision
"not to have him continue
as a lead producer
"of our next live action Spider-Man film.
"Kevin is terrific and we are grateful
"for his help and guidance and appreciate
"the path he has helped put us
on, which we will continue."
But whether it's Disney
or Sony that's to blame,
it doesn't really matter,
because it's the fan's
who are losing, right?
I mean even Hawkeye
himself, Jeremy Renner,
is hoping this gets resolved,
by saying on Instagram,
"Hey Sony Pictures, we want Spider-Man
"back to Stan Lee and
Marvel please, thank you".
Who knows guys, maybe
we'll get some answers soon
seeing as Disney's D23
Expo is this weekend?
- [Peter] Come on man, please.
- But it is time for me
to kick it over to you now
because I have a lot of questions!
What do you think about
an MCU without Spider-Man?
Or Spider-Man without the MCU?
Are you #savespiderman or are you excited
to see what the Sony
Spider-Verse has to offer?
Or are you just waiting
for the next DC movie?
And did Iron Man die for nothing?
Let us know in the comment
section all your feelings!
And for all the latest MCU news
head on over to rottentomatoes.com.
As always, thanks for
watching our show The Ketchup.
I'm Naz Perez and I'm going to send
all my therapy bills
to Sony and Disney now.
(upbeat music)